what will be the remainder if we divide
29 by six we get the quotient as four
and the remainder as five five is the
remainder when 29 is divided by six a
better way to understand this is by
writing it as 29 equals that is the
dividend equals 6 times 4 divides our
time to the quotient plus 5 which is the
remainder the dividend equals the
divisor times the quotient plus the
remainder now look at the remainder and
the divisor can the remainder be greater
than the divisor can this number here be
greater than the number here nope it's
not possible the remainder will always
be less than the divisor it cannot be
equal to the divisor either let's say
you divide 30 by 6 will you write the
quotient as 4 and the remainder as 6
no you will write the quotient as 5 and
the remainder as 0 similarly if the
dividend is 31 you will not write the
quotient as 4 and the remainder at 7 you
will write the quotient as 5 and the
remainder as 1 so if we have something
like n over 6 what will be the possible
remainders they will be 0 1 2 3 4 or 5
all whole numbers less than 6 which is
the divisor let's try out a question
based on this concept we are given that
when a is divided by B the remainder
left is 2 when C is divided by D the
remainder left is 3
assuming a b c and d to be whole numbers
we are asked to find the least value of
b plus D
get the first condition we are given a
divided by B leaves us with a remainder
of 2 it means B cannot be less than or
equal to 2 it has to be greater than 2
the minimum value of B will be 3 it can
be 4 5 6 or higher but the minimum value
is 3 similarly the minimum value of D
will be 4 as the minimum values of B and
D are 3 and 4 the least or the minimum
value of B plus D will be 7 the sum of 3
& 4
let's look at an interesting concept
about remainders 21 divided by 5 gives
us a remainder of 1 and 32 divided by 5
gives us a remainder of 2 in both cases
the divisor is 5 what do you think will
be the remainder when 21 plus 32 is
divided by 5 21 plus 32 is 53 and 53
divided by 5 will leave us with a
remainder of 3 and what is this 3 yes
it's the sum of r1 and r2
when dividends are added over the same
divisor the resulting remainder will be
the sum of the remainders to see if it
always holds true here's another one for
you to try 27 divided by 4
leaves us with a remainder of 3 and 6
divided by 4 leaves us with a remainder
of 2 what will be the remainder when 27
plus 6 is divided by 4 this will be 33
divided by 4 4 times 8 is 32 and we are
left with a remainder of 1
but what is r3 plus r4 3 plus 2 is 5 1
is not the sum of remainders well as a
matter of fact it is only if we remove
the excess from the sum
we know that the remainder cannot be
greater than the divisor so we remove
four from five and are left with one as
the remainder so if you're adding the
remainders do not forget to remove the
excess
you